Good morning. So um let us review what
we learned last class and then we will
discuss the Greeks today. So um as I
discussed last class, there are three
major principles to geopolitics
and once you master an understanding of
these three principles then um you will
see the world much more clearly. Okay.
The first idea is that the competition
uh within
states is greater than the competition
um between or among states. Okay.
And this is the idea of elite
overp production.
So the historian uh Peter Turchin he
looked at the fall of the Roman
Republic, the French Revolution. He
looked at many similar events in human
history and he discovered that what
drives crisis is the fact that you have
too many elite competing for limited
position of status and power. Okay. And
that's what drives a lot of conflict uh
within the nation state. Another way of
framing this is that um the conflict in
states is not between rich and poor but
between the have a lot and have some but
what more. Okay. So usually between the
upper nobility
and the lower nobility.
We see this throughout human history. So
next class we we will discuss the Rome.
Okay. We'll discuss that and we we
understand that a lot of conflict was
between the upper nobility and the lower
nobility. So Julius Caesar
did what he did because he was all the
lower nobility and was trying to reach
the upper nobility. Okay. So this is the
first principle that you need to
understand that what drives a lot of
conflict is elite overproduction. Okay,
that's number one.
Number two is the elite
um has no loyalty.
Okay, this is really important principle
to understand. The elite don't have
loyalty to their people or to their
state or even to the families. They will
do whatever is necessary for them to
accumulate power. Okay.
Um and this idea of Game of Thrones,
right? So, I'm not sure if you've seen
the television show or read the book
series Game of Thrones, but um the world
is Game of Thrones and these people who
love power, they will kill their
parents, they will kill their brothers,
they will kill their own children in
order to amass power from themselves.
Okay, so the game of thrones is a very
nasty affair. The third thing is that
war is often about maintaining that
status quo. Okay? Or the idea of
equilibrium.
[snorts]
If you look at World War I, tens of
millions of people died, okay? And you
cannot possibly understand what happened
or you have problems explaining what
happened because the military strategy
in World War I was so idiotic, right?
You just threw millions of people at
each other. But if you understood that
war is really about maintaining the
status quo that maybe you have access
population of males and if you don't get
rid of them then they will engage you in
the revolution. Okay, you understand
that war is really about maintain the
status quo then war one makes a lot more
sense. Okay. So these are three major
ideas that I want you to understand and
once you understand these three ideas
it's a lot easier for you to understand
the movement of history. Okay. So we're
so we will use an example from Chinese
history so you have you have a clear
understanding of how this works. Okay.
So let's talk about the waring states
period. This is something that hopefully
you all know really well. Okay. So
during the waring states period you had
lots of really powerful states. Okay.
You had the jou,
you had the way, you had the chew. Okay.
And
um at this point in history, you could
believe that any one of the three would
become the empire. They would unite the
entire
um middle kingdom
because they had access to rivers. So
it's easy for them to transport soldiers
and do goods. They had a large
population. They were on fertile ground.
Okay. And then over here is this poor
backward and isolated people called
theQing.
And these were barbarians. Okay.
So how was it possible for theQing who
are these barbarians not very advanced
very poor limited population to
eventually cover all of China? Okay.
Well, once you understand these three
principles, we can now explain it
because what what's happening is that
the jao the way and the true are pretty
stable states. Okay? And so the major
problem is lead over production. The
conflict between the upper nobility and
the lower nobility. And the way that we
resolve the issue is by waging war
against each each other. but waging war
against each other not to conquer each
other but in order to reduce the
domestic conflict within their nation
states and as such war became a ritual
in which it was like a chess game. Okay,
the point was not to destroy each other.
The point was just to maintain
equilibrium, maintain a status quo and
as a result these states became stable.
But another word for stable is stagnant.
And now what's happening is first of all
theQing is being recruited into the wars
because theQing is poor. Therefore they
can provide mercenaries. Okay. Once they
do that what happens is that these
mercenaries learn all the innovations
of the jou way and in terms of military
strategy. Okay. So you have this massive
infusion of innovation into theqing. All
right? So the ching is being energized.
We call this energy, right? Innovation
energy
and ideas.
[snorts] But not only that, but you have
talented people of the low nobility,
right? They want to become officials.
They they want to become generals. But
there's opportunities for them. So where
do they go, guys? They go to the chain.
Okay? Now you have people coming in as
well.
And now what's happening is that theQing
has this massive infusion of energy,
innovation, talent. And so now they can
just bulldoze everyone.
Okay. And now you're like, wait a minute
here. Surely the ja the way the two
recognize the danger of the ching and
they will respond by uniting together
and then destroy the ching. Okay, that
never happens. Why? The reason why is
that
um once you enter an equilibrium,
you understand the world through this
equilibrium. So in their perspective,
the chain becomes stronger. But that's
okay because all we'll do is we'll just
bribe them or we will have them become
part of the system. Why would they want
to take us over? Why can't we just live
happily ever after?
Okay. So it is impossible for the jao
the way of the chu to imagine that
theqing would one day overtake them.
Okay. Another another way of saying this
is that once become once you reach an
equilibrium the people inside the
equilibrium become lazy, stupid and
arrogant.
Okay. And that's and that's why theqing
is easily able to destroy all three
together. In fact, the lower nobility
in all three states probably supported
the takeover, right? Because now they
have opportunities to rise within their
societies.
Okay? And that's the pattern of human
history. And we see this over and over.
All right. So now let's move on to
the west. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
So the equilibrium means that the war
made the com like the status competition
between within the countries more
stable.
>> Yeah. Equilibrium just means they've
reach a balance point. Okay.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. And things are just staying the
same.
>> Oh, okay.
>> And so people think that things will
stay the same forever. So they can't
imagine change happening.
>> But the thing about human society is
that things always change. Okay. So
remember the pattern of the warning
states. Well, guess what? This repeats
over and over. So let's look at
Mesopotamia. So as we discussed about
Mesopotamia, you have the first city
Uric. And what they will do is that as
they expand as a city, they will develop
colonies along the Tigris and Euphrates.
And then these become a waring states as
well. And as we discussed, what will
happen is over time they will reach an
equilibrium. Basically a status quo or
rules to make sure that the elite stay
in power. Okay. And one important rule
that they have is we can we can go to
war against each other but we cannot
destroy each other's temple.
Why? Because the temple is the house of
your patron god. If you kill the patron
god then the god will be very angry and
will kill all of you. Okay? So this
creates an equilibrium because where do
they put all their gold and wealth? The
temple. So you can go and conquer people
but you can't touch their gold and their
wealth and therefore you cannot expand.
Okay. So this creates the idea of
equilibrium. But as I discussed what
happen is that um because of the
equilibrium energy will flow into a poor
exit area called uma and from uma where
a merch named Lucazagi who's like you
know what screw this system I'm going to
go for it all okay so he dares destroy a
temple and before this was unimaginable
because if you destroy a temple the
god's going to come in from heavens and
destroy you right that didn't happen.
But now Lucas Aagi has destroyed the
equilibrium and now he has access to
wealth. And so he's very quickly able to
overwhelm the other city states. At this
time the other city states call for help
from mercenaries, the Aadians who will
come and conquer the entire region,
okay, and establish an empire called the
Aadian Empire led by Sara.
But now that they are an empire, they
will now also reach an equilibrium. And
this talent will flow somewhere else to
energize another region. Okay. So now
what will happen is that the Babylonians
will come. The the Assyrians will come
eventually from the Zagos mountains a
new people called the Persians. Remember
the Persians have a religion called
Zerass will come and conquer all this
area and then they will expand outwards
and conquer both Anatolia
and Egypt.
Okay? And at this point in history, now
there's a new border area called the
Greeks. Okay, the Athenians, Athens and
Sparta.
And Athens and Sparta, the Greeks
encounter Persia because they will send
in mercenaries to help Persia. And these
mercenaries will learn Persian war
tactics and bring them back to Greece.
But not only that, but with an empire,
the Greeks have an opportunity to get
wealthy. How? Through piracy, right?
Piracy.
And then this will force the Persians
now to invade the Greek mainland to stop
this piracy. Okay? Again, this is a
pattern throughout history. The margins
will get wealthy by committing piracy
because why not, right? Okay. And so now
the empire is forced to go invade um
Greece. And guess what? They lose. This
is unimaginable. How is that possible
that some barbarians, the Greeks, are
able to defeat a vast empire, the
world's largest empire, the first great
world empire called the Persians. Well,
this happens all the time. Okay, why?
Well, the pattern is this. Okay, so
let's look at empire.
Let's look at borderlands. Okay,
borderlands are just, you know, the
barbarians. All right, the empire has
three major advantages. mass
organization
and death.
Okay. And what this means is that empire
just is has a lot of people. It has a
centralized bureaucracy. So the
centraliz bureaucracy is is able to
conscript these individuals and it
doesn't matter if they lose a lot of
battles. They uh can keep on throwing
soldiers at the enemy. Okay. But the
borderlands have three advantages that
counteract these three other advantage.
Okay. and they are uh energy
uh openness
and cohesion.
Okay? Meaning that the people work
really hard. They're not afraid to die.
They're open so they want to learn from
other people and they are united as a
people. And this defeats an empire
because the empire the people are not
that energetic. Most of them are slaves
actually. Um the empire is a
bureaucracy. So it's very stagnant. It's
very insular. is close-minded and it's
not and the empire is not united. It's
often divided. Okay, that's why
throughout human history the Borans are
able to conquer the um empire. Okay, so
um
okay so the Persians invade
uh Greece they get c they get defeated
and now Greece becomes the center of the
world or part or major power. Okay. So
let's now discuss Greece.
Okay. So in Greece, remember that we
discussed Greece before and we we said
that Greece becomes the center of
innovation in the world because of three
factors. The first is Homer who is
probably the greatest prophet puppet
poet prophet in human history. Okay. We
read the Iliad together. Pet also wrote
the Odyssey. And these are the two
founding texts of Greek civilization. Um
the alphabet, right? They're now able to
using alphabet write down all their
thoughts and quickly transmit their
thoughts throughout time and space. The
last of course is the polus. Okay, the
polus is their um system of government
where all the citizens are involved in
politics and the polist there's like
thousands of them and they're often
small like maybe a thousand 10,000
people but the two major polices are
Athens
and Sparta.
>> [snorts]
>> And Athens and Sparta are both Greek,
but they're different societies. In
fact, they're nothing alike. Okay, so
let's go over why. Well, first of all,
Sparta is on flat land. The Pelpines.
And if as if you're on flat land, you
can you can use agriculture, but to use
agriculture, you need slaves. Okay? So
Sparta became a war society that
conquered the surrounding people and
turned them into slaves called helotss.
So these helotss
were um yeah surfs slaves who farmed.
And so the Sparta became a war society
based on military dominance. The entire
society was centered around how to take
young boys turn them into great warriors
so that they could they could defend
their land. Okay. The Spartans were also
very conservative.
Why? Because your concern is to maintain
control over the helotss. If you went
over to conquer other places, the helots
could ever could rebel against you.
Okay? And so if you want to know what
this place is like, think China. Okay?
So this is very similar to China. Uh and
as a result of this system, Sparta was
an oligarchy,
meaning ruled by the few. So only
Spartans who were born to both a Spartan
father and a mother were citizens.
Everyone else was not a citizen. So even
your father was Spartan, but your mother
was not Spartan, you were not a citizen.
Okay? So there's a massive class
hierarchy in Sparta. And the reason why
is for them the priority was to maintain
the status quo. Okay? The Athenians are
a different people. The Athenians don't
have good farmland, but they have a good
harbor.
Okay. So, and the territory around them,
it's mountainous, so they can't really
grow crops, but they do, but they are
able to grow a crop called olives. Okay?
So, they have a lot of olive trees.
[snorts]
And so, what happens is the Athenians
have no choice but to be expansionist.
Okay? So they built a really strong navy
[clears throat] and they focus on trade
and piracy and that's how they sustain
themselves over time. So whereas the
Spartans are conservative, the Athenians
are both open and expansionist.
And also what's really important to
understand is that if you're a navy, you
have to be a democracy.
The rule in
um Greece is that you fight for us, you
can vote, you can speak in public, you
can participate in politics. Now um
Sparta was a land army with hoplets.
Hobblelets are elite soldiers and as a
result they were an oligarchy. Okay,
because only a few of them fought. But
Athens was a uh democracy because it had
a navy. In a navy, everyone could roll.
Okay? To be h you to buy weaponry, you
have to train for like decades. But the
Athenians had a navy where anyone can
just roll. Okay? And so they were a
democracy.
All right? And so over time, because
Athens is democracy that's expanding,
Sparta is um a land power. Um Athens
will start to increase in power. Sparta
will decrease in power and eventually
these two will come in conflict with
each other. Okay. In something called
the Pelpedian war.
Eventually this gives rise to thieves
and eventually over time these three
states Athens thieves and Sparta will
reach a equilibrium. Okay. So similar to
the waring states where they inter each
other and they use war as a way to
resolve their domestic tensions as
opposed to try to conquer each other.
And this gives opportunity for a new
power to arise that was previously
thought of off as backward, poor and
isolated. And this power is called
Macedonia.
So what Macedonia is going to do is
they're going to take all the major
military innovations of Sparta, thieves,
and Athens to create the world's most
powerful army. Okay? And what else
they're going to do is they're going to
recruit a lot of talent from these
places. And then what's going to happen
is that Macedonia is going to come and
conquer the entire Greek mainland. The
Macedonians will be the first to unite
Greece.
Okay. Now, who who's doing all this? His
name is Philin.
Okay. Philip Sen is probably the
greatest military genius, one of the
greatest military geniuses in human
history. But we don't remember him
because he has a son who's actually more
famous than he is. And his name is
who?
Axen the Great.
Why is Axen the Great more famous?
Because Aon the Great will take
everything that Phil built and he will
use it to conquer Persia.
Okay.
And
um then what will happen is that as this
system reaches another equilibrium a new
power rise that will overflow this
entire system and this power is called
>> Rome okay which we will discuss next
class okay so you see how this pattern
works right it's a consistent pattern
throughout human history
all right okay so
what happened is that action the
will
conquer the Persian Empire. All right.
Uh where's the Persian Empire? Egypt,
Anatolia,
the Levant,
Mesopotamia,
this is Persia.
Um okay. So this is like the entire
world and like this small army. Okay,
it's not even the entire Greek army.
It's basically it's Macedonians only.
This small army, the Macedonians,
they're able to come and they're able to
conquer all of it. Okay. And the
question then is how? Well, the same
reason why uh theQing was able to
conquer the Jou the way in the Chu,
right? because of elite competition,
elite overp production within these
areas
because um these elites have no loyalty.
So so a lot of these leads were
switching sides over time. So what
probably happened was that these certain
elites invited Alexander to come over
and then he switched sides. So he was
very quickly able to bulldoze. Also
remember that when you reach an
equilibrium you become lazy, stupid and
arrogant. Right? So this guy Darius, he
is now the um
king of kings. Okay? He's leading the
Persians and he always believed that at
some point Alexander would stop. Okay?
He'd be like, "You know what? You have
Egypt, you have the Levant, you have
Anatolia, you have parts of Mesopotamia.
You know what I'll do? I'll give you all
this territory plus I'll give you half
my treasury." So Darius thought he could
just bribe Alexander and his father Phil
would have been like, "That's a great
deal. I'm happy." Sure.
But Alexander was not like that. Okay.
Alexander is considered himself the son
of God.
And you will discover that all these
great conquerors believe that they are
divinity that they are a son of God and
they came on earth in order to unify the
world. Okay. Genghask Con was like this.
Julius Caesar was like was like this.
Napoleon was like this. All these great
conquerors are unlimited.
Like their appetite for conquest is
insatiable.
So, and this was unimaginable for these
people. Like we're giving you like all
the money in the world. And I said
that's not enough. Okay. we'll give the
entire world. That's not enough, man. I
want it all. So, he kept on going and he
killed D. Sorry. And then Darius died
and he conquered the entire um Persian
Empire. The problem though is that
Alexander was being co-opted by the
Persian elite. Remember, it was part of
the Persian elite that invited Alexander
to come over and a lot of the Persian
elite were switching sides. So Alexander
was incorporating more and more of the
Persian elite into his army as well as
into his administration and so his
Macedonian army is not happy about this.
So they get they get together and they
assassinate him. Okay. And now the world
is divided among his generals. Okay. And
this creates what we call the Henistic
age.
Okay. The world of the Greeks. And what
is special about this world is now all
three major cultures that came after the
collapse of the bronze age. The Jews,
the uh Greeks and the Persians come
together in what we call synretatism.
Synatism just means a combining of
religions to create the basis for
western civilization. Okay. The
secretism will also give birth to a new
religion that forever changes the world
and it is called
Christianity.
Okay. So Christianity is comes from a
merger
of these three major worldviews.
Okay. Now once the Greeks talk of the
world, they have a problem which is
there's not that many of them. Okay. So
how do they control the world? Well,
they control the world through religion,
through culture. So the what they will
do is um a man named Aristotle
who is um
Macedonian and and like this is
something that you do not learn in
history class and it is such an
important fact. Okay, but the important
fact is this. Philip the second the man
who conquered Greece and Aristotle
consider one of the most famous
philosophers in human history. They were
childhood best friends. Okay, they grew
up together and it's something that you
will never ever learn in school. Okay,
but it's a very important fact that you
you you need to understand. So, so way
of saying this is that um the
Macedonians had a plan of the world for
a long long time. So, what would happen
is that Phili would go to Greece to
learn all the military innovations but
Aristotle would go to learn all the
intellectual innovations of Greece. So
his teacher was Plato.
Okay. So he learned from Plato and the
academy. And what will do is he will
take Greek knowledge, he will systemize
it into a knowledge of empire. Okay. So
what do I mean by that?
All right. So we discussed Plato.
We discussed how for Plato what matters
is the spirit, the mind. create the
soul, the immaterial. So this is the
good or the god, the good and the good
emanates and creates the shadow world
which is the world that we live in. But
our goal in life is to return to the
good by seeking knowledge, by learning
truth, um by learning something called
sacred geometry. So for Plato, secret
geometry are these shapes that underpin
reality. Okay? So once you're able to
master sacred geometry, you're able to
master the fabric of the universe.
And so that's what Plato taught. Now, if
you're an empire, you don't want this
crap. Okay? Why? Because as an empire,
you want to maximize the energy of each
individual. You want the person to work
as hard as possible to make as much
money as possible because that energy
then can be sucked up by the empire.
Okay? If you're just sitting around
reading books, that's we don't want that
crap. Okay? So now what Aristotle has to
do is create a new philosophy that
counter counters Plato.
Actually, Aristotle probably didn't
create this. He probably stole it from
someone else. Okay? But the philosophy
is very simple. For Aristotle, he
doesn't talk about the spirit world. He
only talks about the material world.
Okay? For for Aristotle, what makes the
world move is cause and effect.
So I push you, you move forward, you
move forward, you bump someone else, and
that person bumps into someone else.
Okay? Cause and effect. Now this this
theory implies that there must have been
a god called a prime mover.
Okay? Because someone must have been the
first to move things. That person must
have been God. Okay? But what's
important about the in this idea is the
prime move doesn't matter because the
prime move is the first move.
We don't have to worry about him
anymore. Okay? All we have to worry
about is the goal. The end. Okay? We
don't have to worry about the beginning.
We have to worry about the end. What is
the end? The end is something called
tilos.
Telos. Okay? Purpose. Okay? When what
this means is that we're all here to
achieve our purpose in life. Okay? So
you are students. What's your purpose?
To learn. So if you learn
if you learn, you become a good student
because you're fulfilling your purpose.
I'm a teacher. My purpose is to teach as
well as I can. Okay? So work hard and
produce energy for the empire. Okay? So
that this is the Aristotle um idea. This
is important. uh because
this conflict between Plato and
Aristotle is really the underlying
conflict in all of Western philosophy.
Okay, we'll see this all the time. We
will see this emerge in um Europe with
um and so Plato becomes what we call the
rationalist. So Decart
and
becomes what we call the empiricist.
Okay. So please remember this conflict
empiricis.
All right.
Plato believes in mind over matter.
Aristotle says mind doesn't matter.
Let's focus on matter. Okay. That's all
that matters. I don't know mind mine.
Let's just focus on matter. Okay. And
the British Empire will adopt this idea.
In fact, all empires will adopt this
idea, including the American Empire.
All right.
Okay. Any questions before
um we go to the PowerPoint? This is all
clear.
All right. So, let's go to the
PowerPoint.
The Greek legacy.
Okay.
All right. So, as I discussed, the
geography of Greece is really important.
So, Greece is a very poor place that is
mountainous and hilly. So it's almost
impossible for an empire to develop in
Greece because there's not enough
wealth, there's not enough um resources
to support an empire. So so during this
time there are thousands of polices that
are in conflict with each other and this
allows for massive innovation. What's
also important about Greece is that it
is by the sea which allows Greece to
access different parts of the world.
Okay. If you cross the Aian, you get
into Persia, which is the wealthiest
part of the world. The Mediterranean
gives you access to Egypt as well as to
northern Africa as well. Okay, so Greece
really benefited from this geography.
That's why uh Greece was so innovative
because you can actually steal knowledge
from Egypt. It steal a lot of knowledge
from Egypt. Okay, that's something that
is not really knowledge, but you can see
how close Egypt is. Okay. So, uh the
Greeks sold a lot of knowledge from
Egypt and from Anatolia, Mesopotamia and
Persia. But they also steal knowledge
from uh northern Europe as well. Okay.
Um so remember that the two major city
states are Sparta and Athens. Um thieves
is the third major city state. Macedonia
is up here somewhere. So where's
Macedonia? Around here somewhere. Okay.
And uh the thing about Macedonia is that
throughout most of this history it
doesn't really matter
and throughout this mo most of this
history is actually a subject of Persia.
It's a very mountainous area and so it
was poor backwards for the longest time.
Okay.
Okay. So this is a map of Sparta. Now,
Sparta becomes the military power of the
Greeks because um as you can see the
Pelpine
it's pretty flat which allows for
agriculture. With agriculture you need
slaves. So the Spartans had to go
conquer the people and turn them into
slaves called the helotss. And their
main concern in life became how do we
keep the helotss under control because
they're outnumbered 10 to one.
Okay. So the helotss were both the major
resource of Sparta, but they also the
major danger to Sparta. And Sparta
didn't really care about anyone else.
So the Spartans were concerned first and
foremost about how to turn their boys
into warriors. And so the first thing
they did that's most important is they
took the children away at age six or
seven or five. Okay? Because remember we
discussed this previously. If you want
people to be great warriors, you have to
create anxiety in them. Okay? If they
are loving people, they don't want to
kill other people. But if they are
divorced from their parents, they have
conflict with their parents, they don't
really like life, they really got
killing. Okay? So these boys were take
was were taken away from parents at age
uh five or six. And then they were put
with other boys where they were beat up
every day. They were beat up every
single day. when they were 14 15 they um
had a mentor who was like maybe 30 years
old and they became lovers okay and
that's how you build commie um
fraternity in the army and then when
1819 they had initiation um ceremony
where at night they would hide in the
fields and wait for a helot a slave to
break curfew. Okay. If if you stay up
outside, if you stay outside
um beyond sun um set, then you broke the
law. And so what these soldiers would do
is they would hide, wait for a hella to
break curfew, and then go and slit the
guy's throat. Okay? And that was
basically the graduation ceremony for
the spawn. This this is a brutal, brutal
people. But guess what guys? The the
Romans were the same thing. The Aztecs
were the same thing. The Americans are
the same thing. Okay.
All right. So, um, what's important to
understand is that at this time in
history, the Greeks are developing
massive innovation in military warfare
because they're always at war with each
other. And the major innovation is
called the hoplights. Okay, the
hoplights is basically to create a wall
together so you can bulldo over your
enemy. Also in this time in history, the
Persians are developing horse archers
and this is a major military innovation
for them.
What's really important for us to
understand is like the these two
innovations happen because of their
distinct geography. You couldn't have
horse archers in Greece because the land
is too hilly. The land is too poor to
support horse archery. Okay? You
couldn't have hoplights in Persia
because the land is too wide. Okay? So
what this means is that yes, Persia is
the dominant empire in the world, but
when they go to Greece to attack the
Greeks, they cannot use their horse
archers, which is their major military
innovation. And as a result, the Greeks
are able to use hoplights and bulldo
over the Persians.
All right. So this is the battle of
Marathon, which is the first great
military engagement between the Greeks
and the Persians. The Greeks again, the
Athenians, especially Athenians, they're
going and causing a lot of problems for
Persians. They are they're committing
piracy. They're also going around and
encouraging Greeks under uh the Persian
rule to not pay taxes. Greeks do not
like to pay taxes. It's still true in
today. Okay? Uh Greeks hate paying
taxes. And so this is the first major
mil confrontation between the Athenians
and the the Persians called the Battle
of Marathon. And this is 490 BCE. and
the Athenians won because as I told you,
the Persians use horse archers. They
can't use horse archers in Greece.
They're forced to use um infantry. But
when it comes to infantry versus
infantry, the Greeks are are the best at
that. So avoid head-on collisions with
the Greeks. Okay?
All right. So um this will lead to a
series of wars between Persia and Greece
and what will happen is that there will
be two major in invasions and they will
both fail. Okay, the the one that I'm
most uh interested in is the purple.
Okay, this is the last major invasion of
the Persians into Greece. What will
happen is that they will create this
land bridge. Okay. Uh on the Bosphorus
they basically have ships. It's a land
bridge and they will cross over and this
leads to the famous battle of Ferupi.
Okay. You may have seen the movie 300
where 300 Spartans stood stood against
like you know a lot of Persians. Well uh
the Persians eventually crush the uh
Spartans and what they will do is they
will take Leonitis who's the king of
Spartans and they will cut off his head
and put him on the pike. Okay. And that
this is considered a major insult to the
Greeks. Then what they will do is they
will go to Athens uh which is here and
they will burn down Athens. And at this
point the war should be over, right?
But what happens is the Athenians are
like you know what we're a polless. A
polus is not a place. It's a people. So
what we'll do is we'll get on our ships
and sell off. And the Persians are like
you can't do that man. Athenian is like
yeah we can man. So Athenians are sell
off and the war continues. Okay, Athena
should have been destroyed but it's not
destroyed and [snorts] at this point the
Persian have won the war and all the
Persians have to do is stay where they
are and land their navy. Okay, they have
a massive navy into Sparta because
Sparta has a weakness, right? Sparta has
helots. So all they do is land in Sparta
and the helots will rise up against
Sparta and the war is over. Game over.
Okay. The problem with empires is
they're lazy, stupid, and arrogant.
Okay. So, um, Xerxes, who's leading this
invasion,
he thinks that, you know what, this
strategy of winning the war for
attrition is not honorable because I
want to go back and build a monument to
myself. Okay? So, I want to face the
Greeks in a major confrontation. And
this confrontation is called the battle
of Salamus. Okay? the battle of Salamus.
And as I where's Salamus? Um yeah, right
here. Okay. And this is considered the
greatest naval battle in human history
because it forever changed the course of
human history. Now, at this point, I I
keep on saying this, the war is over.
You don't have to do anything. Just let
troops into Sparta uh the Pelpineese and
the Hellet will rise up and destroy the
Spartans and the war is over. You've
conquered all of Greece. Okay? do not
risk your navy in a military
confrontation.
So of course the the Persians decide
we're going to risk our navy and so this
leads to the battle of Salamus which
ever again forever changed the course of
human history.
All right.
Um so this this is another map showing
you what what happens. Okay. And now we
are in the battle of Salamus.
Um and we know about the battle cylus
because of a name named Herodotus uh uh
Heroditus who wrote a book called
histories and he's considered a father
of history because he wrote the first
historical work. What he did is he
basically went around Greece and he
collected memories of the Persian wars
um a few decades after the fact and he
wrote it all down. Okay. Um if you read
the histories it's really funny. It's
really interesting but we have to take
it with a grain of salt. Okay. Okay. So
he writes about the battle of uh ferupi.
Okay. And again at this point in his
history the war is over. You don't have
to do anything.
[sighs]
But again Xerxes says I want a monument.
Okay. I want to witness a great climic
battle between my navy and the Greek
navy. Okay. So he sends his navy into
battle and of course they get destroyed
because again it's really important you
don't fight the Greeks face on. Okay,
you don't do that because the Greeks are
heavily armored and you're not. Okay, so
um this is a Greek uh tri. Okay, so
Greek tri the thing to to recognize
about is it's mainly soldiers. So
they're really fast. They have some uh
soldiers on top, marines on top. Okay.
So, they're really good at ramming you
and destroying your ship. The leader of
the Athenian Navy, his name is Fezicles.
And Fzles is one of the greatest
generals in Athenian history. He's
actually the guy who proposed that
Athens build a navy. Um, Athens
discovered a silver mine and they use
all the silver to build their navy to
prepare for the Persian invasion. Okay?
And it was Fezicles who led the
Athenians against the Persians.
Okay? And this is what the battle looks
like. Okay? So you have you still have
this massive Persian army converging
against the Athenians. But again guys,
don't fight the Greeks head on. Okay? So
they're like, you know, we're going to
fight them head on. So you see this
massive army converging against the
Athenians.
And now they're they're they're
converging against each other. Okay.
And the Athenians destroy them. Okay.
Yeah. Don't fight the Greeks head on.
All right. And now the entire Persian
Navy is scattered. The war is over now
because now the Persians have lost their
navy, which means that they cannot
resupply. They have no more no mobility.
And so what will happen next is that the
uh so yeah the Athenians destroy the
Persian navy. What happened next is
um the Spartans will not want to destroy
the remaining Persian forces in Greece.
Okay, this is why you don't do I can't
I'm sorry. It's just the dumbest thing
I've ever seen. Okay, they won the war
and they screwed it up. Okay. Um once
you lose a Navy, you can't resupply.
Once you re once you can't resupply
you've lost the war. All right. So this
is from Heroditus. All right. Um so
what's going to happen is the war the
battle of Salamas is lost and but you
know the Persian still have this huge
army in Greece and so the Athenian g
sorry the Persian king Xerxes he's he's
like I'm out of here man. You know I
came here to burn down Athens. I've done
that. I'm gonna go home now and I'm
gonna let my general Monius take care of
the Greeks. Okay, so Mononius is like,
you know, I don't really want to fight
these guys anymore. So Monius sends an
envoy to the Athenians and said, "You
know what? The king of kings, York, says
this, we're really sorry we burned down
your city. Really sorry we burned down
your temple, but we'll give you a lot of
money, so please stop fighting us."
Okay. Um, and this is what the envoy
says to the Athenians. Okay, can you
read, please?
Why are you so mad as to love your war
against the king? For neither can you
get the better off him, nor can you
resist him forever. You are acquainted
with the multitude of Xerxes army and
their achievements. You have heard of
the force that is even now with me. So
that even if you should get the better
of us and conquer of which however you
can't have no hope if you think soberly
another much more numerous will come
against you.
>> Okay. So this is idea of empire, right?
Just mass organization and death. We are
infinite in our resources. We are
infinite in our wealth. We can just
throw army after army after army against
you. Athenians, you're like this small
little city. Okay, give up already. And
the Athenians respond
with this. Okay.
>> We ourselves are aware of this that the
power of the Medis
>> mess. Meets me is Persian. Okay. Oh,
mess is far greater than ours, so that
there was no need to insult us with
that. But nevertheless, being ardent for
liberty, we will defend ourselves in
such manner as we are able. But do not
you attempt to persuade us to come to
terms with the barbarian, for we will
not be persuaded. Go then, and tell
Mardonius that the Athenians say, "So
long as the sun shall continue in the
same course as now, we will never make
terms with Xerxes. But we will go out to
oppose him trusting in the gods who
fight for us and in the heroes whose
temples and images he holding them in no
reverence has burned.
>> Okay. So these two passes show you the
difference between empire and the
borderlands. Right? The empire is about
mass organization death. The borderlands
the Greeks are about openness energy and
cohesion. Okay. The Athenian say to the
persons we know you're bigger than us.
We know you're stronger than us, but we
believe in liberty. We believe in each
other. We believe in our gods. And
therefore, we'll fight you to the end.
Okay.
All right. So, what will happen is that
now that Xerxes is gone, now that the
navy is scattered, Mardonis is kind of
screwed. Okay. And so, what will happen
is the Spartans face off against
Mardonis in the battle of Palia and they
they will destroy uh Mardonis. Mardonis
is killed. And so one of the soldiers
says to the king of the Spartans, "Uh,
Passenius, Pacenius, your uncle Leonitis
was killed by the Persians and they put
his head on a spike. Why don't you
return the favor and put the head of
Mardonius on a on a sp on on a pike and
show it to the world and show how great
the Greeks are?" This is Pson's response
to this. Okay, can you read? Posonius
answered, "I admired your good
intentions and your foresight, but you
have failed to form a right judgment for
having highly extolled extolled me, my
country, and my achievement. You have
thrown all down against me uh to nothing
by advising me to insult a dead body,
and saying that if I do, so I shall
increase my fame, which is more fit for
barbarians to do than Greeks, and which
we uphore even in them. I cannot
therefore in this matter please the
uh
>> ajini
>> ajini nor those who nor those to whom
such things should be pleasing. It is
sufficient for me to please the Spartans
by doing and speaking what is right. As
Leonitis
>> Leonitis whose death you exhort me to
avenge, I affirm that he has been amply
avenged. Both he and all the others who
fell at their mob play have been avenged
by the countlessness of these men.
However, do not you hereafter come to me
with such a proposal, nor give such
advice, and be thankful that you escaped
unpunished.
>> Okay, so what he's saying is that we won
because the gods favor us. Why do the
gods favor us? Because we are virtuous.
Because we are loyal to the gods. We're
loyal to ourselves. We are not the
barbarians. We are not the Persians. We
are the Spartans.
Okay. So you can see at this time in
history how
um for the Greeks what matters is their
virtue, their faith and their loyalty.
Okay? But guess what? This all changes
when they become an empire. Okay? So I I
want you guys to remember this. And what
we're going to do now is we're going to
compare and contrast this when what
happens when they become an empire.
Okay? Um Okay.
All right. So, the Persians are
scattered and they're never they're
never going to come back and now it's
the Athenian Empire. And so, what um the
Athenians propose is, you know what,
it's always possible that the Persians
will want to return. So, we need to set
up a alliance to defend ourselves
against the Persians. Okay? And they
call it the Dillian League. Why? because
they agree that they will pull the
resources together as a defense fund
against the uh person. So think of like
NATO, okay, the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization. They agree that they will
put all their gold in a place called
Delos, okay? An island in Delos
somewhere. Um yeah, it's somewhere.
Yeah, it's right here. It's a small
island in Del right here. Okay, you guys
see it? [clears throat] And so no one no
one's allowed to touch this. So what
happens is that the Athenians are like
you know what it's probably safer with
us. So the Athenians steal all this gold
and now the Dian league is no long is no
longer a alliance but a empire the
Athenian empire where everyone now has
to pay tribute to Athens. Okay. So all
that's happened is before these Greek
city states have to pay tribute to the
Persians and now they have to pay
tribute to the Athenians. Okay. It's
probably a worst deal for everyone. And
what do the Athenians do with all this
gold? They spend it on this. Okay, it's
called the Parthonon. It's still there
in Athens if you you want to go visit
it. It's it's lost its former glory.
Okay, but this is what the Parthonon
looked like during the age of Pericles,
during the age of the Athenian Empire.
Okay, this is a statue of uh Athena.
It's pure gold. They didn't have to do
this, but they were like, you know what?
we're going to enjoy our empire. They
built uh the the Athenian statue. Okay.
And so at this time in history, the
Athens is beautiful. It's wealthy. And
what that does is it makes you lazy,
arrogant, and stupid. Okay.
All right. So this is fusidities and he
wrote um the pelpina war um and he
discusses
why Athens went to war with Sparta.
Okay. And what he says is well it's
because Sparta is the hegeimon and
Athens is the rising power and therefore
they were bound to clash. Okay. That's
not what happened. Athens was the
hedgeimon. happens with the empire and
his allies were rebelling against it and
it would it drag Sparta into the war.
Okay, that's what that's what what what
really happened.
All right, so this is what the war looks
like. The Athenians have their empire,
the Spartans have their alliances, and
what's going to happen is the allies are
going to try to break out of the
Athenian empire. Okay? And they're going
to drag Sparta into the war. Sparta does
not want to fight Athens. But Athens
forces Sparta to fight it because Athens
is very expansionist. Okay. So you can
see how this red is now encroaching on
the Pelpineese which is historically
uh Spartan uh territory. Right now the
problem is that remember Sparta has a
weakness. The helotss if the Athenas
ever choose to land forces on its coast
the Helotss would all rise up together
and overwhelm the Spartans. Okay. So
Sparta must protect its periphery from
uh Athenian encroachment. So this is
what leads to the war. Okay, this
doesn't make sense. Okay, Sparta does
not want this war. The Athenians are
extremely aggressive. They're expanding
everywhere and Sparta is forced into
this war. The allies use this
opportunity in order to try to break out
of the Athenian uh empire. And so most
of Palinian war is actually between
Athens and its former colonies and
allies. Okay? because Athens is a mafia
state. Now what's important for us to
understand is that because of the nature
of this war, the way they fought the war
was strange. Okay, so Sparta is not
trying to destroy Athens and Athens is
not is not trying to destroy Sparta.
It's really easy for Athens to destroy
Sparta, right? All Athens has to do is
land forces in Sparta and let the Hella
to rise up. But Athens doesn't want to
do that because they will destroy the
equilibrium. Okay? You don't know what
would happen if the allot helots were to
take control of Sparta. They might come
after you Athens. Okay, so Athens is
status quo power. Therefore, it wants to
maintain the equilibrium. Now, let me
ask you this question. How could Sparta
defeat Athens very easily, right? They
could just free the hell out. Right now,
their army rises 10 times. They can now
overwhelm Athens. But doesn't want to do
that because it would destroy their
equilibrium. Okay? It would destroy
their social order. It would destroy
their oligarchy. It would create a
democracy. basically and they don't they
don't want that. Okay, so they're trying
to they're trying to fight the war in a
way that allows to maintain equilibrium
and that's why the war is fought in a
very strange way. Okay, they're not
trying to destroy each other. They're
trying to maintain a balance of power.
What will happen is that Sparta will
eventually defeat Athens. But choose not
to destroy Athens because if destroy
Athens then thieves and other powers
could arise which could challenge
Sparta. Okay. Right.
>> [snorts]
>> All right. So the leader of um Athens at
this time is Pericles and Pericles is
famous for the funeral which is
considered like the most famous speech
in um western civilization. And I I I'm
sorry uh but in university they will
teach you that the funeral is a speech
about democracy. It's not a speech about
democracy. If you actually read it, it's
a speech about empire. Okay. Um, for
whatever reason, the British and
Americans believe that Athens was the
greatest democracy in the world and they
can do no wrong. No, no, no. It's an
empire and it's concerned only with
maintaining its empire. Okay. So, we're
going to read from the funeralation. And
the thing remember about funeralation is
that Athens is not at war. Lots of
Athenians are getting killed in this war
and the custom is for uh there to be a
massive state funeral to celebrate the
war dead and they give a a a speech to
commemorate the war dead. Okay. So we
can't read all the speech but I want to
show you a very important paragraph in
the speech. Okay.
All right.
[clears throat]
Comfort therefore not condolence non
>> condolence
is what I have to offer to the parents
of the dead who may be here. Numberless
are the chances to which as they know
the life of man is subject but fortunate
indeed are they who draw for their lot
of lot of death so glorious that which
has caused your mourning. Yet who you
yet you who are still of an age to beget
children must spare up in the hope of
having others in their steedstead.
Not only will they help you to forget
those whom you have lost but will be to
the state at once a reinforcement and a
security.
>> Okay. So he's talking to these uh
parents whose sons are now dead. Okay.
And remember like during the Persian
wars the Athenians are like we're a
virtuous people. We believe in liberty.
We believe in our gods. We believe in
each other. And that's why we'll win
this war. Okay. Now, what Pericles is
saying to these parents is, you know
what? Your sons were useless anyway. But
now they died for empire, which is good,
right? Now, you can be proud of your
sons who are worthless. But now that
they died for empire, we can't celebrate
them. So, what should you guys do? You
should have more children so that you
can protect the empire. Okay.
All right, that's what he's saying. He's
also saying to
um the Athenians, listen, I know these
men are dead and they have children, but
don't worry because what we're going to
do is we will put these children into an
into an orphanage and raise up to be
soldiers so that so that they can go and
fight for the empire and die like their
fathers. Okay, this is now empire, guys.
[snorts]
All right. So, um, this is the plague of
Athens. So, again, what Perules should
be doing is embarking on a massive war
of expansion against the Sparta and
Sparta would lose very quickly. Perles
doesn't do that because he doesn't want
to fight the Spartans. If he defeats the
Spartans, it creates an imbalance of
power in the Greek mainland. Okay? So
what he does is he forces everyone to
seek shelter within Athens because
remember Sparta is a land power. He
doesn't want to face Sparta on land. So
he forces everyone to go into Athens and
hide behind the city walls. Guess what
happens if you put a lot of people in
one place? You get the play, guys. Okay,
this kills a third of the Athenian
population, including Pericles and his
two sons.
All right, so uh can you read can you
read this? So what's happening is that
you have the these different islands who
are either rebelling against Athenians
or who say to the Athenians, we don't
want to be part of the stupid war. Okay?
And Athenians go to them and says, "Too
bad, guys." Okay, keep on going.
Athenians, for ourselves, we shall not
trouble you with spaces
>> specious species pretenses either of how
we have a right to our empire because we
overthrew the meat or are now attacking
you because of wrong that you have done
us and make a long speech which would
not be which not be believed. And in
return, we hope that you instead of
thinking to influence us by saying that
you did not join the list as a
>> these are the Spartans. Okay.
>> Sedonians although they're colonists or
that you have done us no wrong, we'll
aim at what is feasible holding in view
that holding view the real sentiments of
us both. Since you know as well as we do
that right as the world goes is only in
question between equals in power while
the strong do what they can and the weak
suffer what they must.
>> Okay. So you know the Persians when they
went to the Athenians basically said we
are a vast empire. You can't defeat us
and let's just be friends. And and and
now now that the Athenians have defeated
the Persians now they're the empire.
Basically, what they say to everyone
else is, "We're not even going to bother
trying to be your friends. We're not
even going to bother trying to convince
you that we're right and you're wrong.
We're just stronger than you to shut up
and obey." Okay? This is the entire
point of the Athenians. The Athenians
are even worse than the Persians. Okay?
Remember the the Athenians fought the
Persians for liberty. Once they become
an empire
and others want liberty, too bad because
Athenians are stronger. Might makes
right. Okay.
All right. Um, so this war will drag on
and because as an empire you become
lazy, stupid and arrogant, the Athenians
will do stupid things like go invade a
uh [clears throat] people that don't
even that even not part of this war.
Okay, Sicily. So remember um the
Athenians, it's a mafia state. What they
do is they collect tribute from the
allies. But as this war is stragging on,
they need more and more money. So they
decide to go conquer conquer more and
more people. So they decide let's go
conquer Sicily because it's very
wealthy. They send a massive expedition
against Sicily. They get they lose and
they drag Syracuse which has a navy into
the war. Now Sparta, Syracuse combined
against the Athenians and the Persians
come in as well. Okay. The allies go
turn against spar f Athens and what they
will do is they will blockade athens
from uh fric which is where Athens gets
most of its wheat. Okay. So now Athens
is going to starve. So Athens surrenders
and this ends the pelpian war and this
time as remember that Spartans could
choose to destroy Athens. They don't
choose to because they're not interested
in winning the war. They're only
interested in maintain the status quo
equilibrium. Okay.
And of course this gives rise to
Macedonia. Okay. Now remember this is
really important for the second what he
will do is he will go into the Greek
mainland and learn all the major
innovations of the theans the Athenians
and the Spartans. He will create
something called the master fallank
which becomes the most dominant military
force in history at this point. He has a
child best friend Aristotle who will go
to Athens and learn from Plato and he
will systemize all Greek knowledge so
that so that he can take this knowledge
and turn it into a um tool of empire.
Okay. Okay. So um
Phil the second will focus on military
conquest of the world but will focus on
cultural imperialism. Okay.
All right. So what makes Philip such a
genius is to understand listen Persians
have their horse archers, the Athenians
and the Spartans have their hopes. Okay.
So but what I can do is I I can take all
these major innovations together and
combine them into one military package
and that allows me for coordination.
Okay? So I can have flexibility and
mobility in my army. The problem though
is like for that to happen you need to
make sure that every soldier is highly
motivated that every soldier wants to
fight. Now traditionally um if you have
an army different section of your army
get special privileges. Okay usually the
cavalry because these are aristocrats
they get all the privileges and everyone
else their life sucks. But what Philip
the second understood is like no no no I
need to make sure that everyone is
happy. So he focused on increasing the
morale of his soldiers. And it's very
easy guys, okay? All you do is be
metocratic. If a soldier is doing a good
job, you promote him. If a soldier is
doing a bad job, you demote him. And you
think that's easy, but it's not because
what it what it means is you have to
overturn the social hierarchy. Okay?
Because the aristocrats are just used to
like doing whatever they want. But Phil
was insistent. No, no, no. Every soldier
will be treated fairly. This is going to
be a meritocracy and this is what
allowed him to create the world's
greatest army. Okay. Now once you have
these different forces in place you can
now have major military innovation and
what is major military innovation was
something called the anvil and hammer.
Okay. Basically what would happen is
like your infantry will lock with the
other infantry in place. Okay. This
called the anvil. And then what will
happen is your cavalry will sweep in
from behind to smash the enemy cavalry.
This called the hammer. And this is what
allowed Alexandra to conquer all of
Persia because no other army had
witnessed such a powerful force and you
can't really possibly respond to it.
Okay, once the army once the infantry
locks you in place, you can't escape.
Then the cavalry comes in and smashes
you in apart. Okay, the anvil and the
hammer.
So what will happen is that um Phil the
second will go conquer Greece because
remember at this time Greece are
dividing into city states. They're all
fighting each other and they're not
interested in actually conquering each
other. They're just interested in
maintaining equilibrium. So, Philip the
second is like, you know what, screw the
system. I'm going to come break all the
rules and I'm going to conquer everyone.
So, this is the battle of Sherania,
which is where he defeats a combined
force of Athenians and Athenians. And
now he controls all of uh mainland
Greece. And now he's ready to do what is
what he really wants, which is to
conquer Persia. Why? Because Persia is
where the money is, right? Greece is
poor. Persia is wealthy. Therefore, I'm
I'm gonna take this army and go conquer
Persia.
Um, so this is the year 336
when Philip II has conquered all
mainland Greece and he's now ready to
invade Persia. In fact, he has also
spies throughout Persia. He also has
diplomats throughout Persia negotiating
with the local elites. Okay? So, he's
now ready to go and conquer uh Persia.
Uh, unfortunately, he gets killed. Okay.
So, he goes to the wedding of his
daughter and his bodyguard kills him.
And there's historical debate as to who
killed this, but the answer is pretty
simple. Okay. His wife, uh, his wife,
Olympias.
Why would Olympia, who is the mother
Alexander the Great, kill her husband?
It's really, really simple.
Um, if you're a king, you marry a lot of
foreign women for alliances. Olympias is
not Macedonian.
And um so there's a lot of people in the
Macedonian court who who dislike her.
Abel the great is here to the throne but
as a young man he was notorious for
being a thug. Okay he's not like Phil is
very deliberate. He's very strategic. A
the great is basically a thug. So Philin
was worried about about the great. So
later in his life he married a
Macedonian woman and they had a son
together. Okay. What this means now is
that this son is now here to the throat
and not the great Olympias taught
Alexander the Great from day one that
you are special Alexander. You are not
the son of Philip the second. You're the
son of God. Son of God. Okay. And so
Olympias when she felt that Philip
second was about to steal the throne
from Alexander she had him killed and we
know because after the Philip second was
killed who else did she kill the wife
the the new Macedonian wife as well as
the son right okay so this is a nasty
person Philip the Asen the great will
take Philip's great army and he will go
conquer Persia with it okay and this is
what his conquest path looks like he
will do this in like 10 years time.
He'll conquer like the entire world
basically in 10 years time. What's
important is the way that he moves.
Okay, he moves really quickly with small
army which tells us that he needed
cooperation from local elites. Okay,
remember at this time in history uh
Persia has reached an equilibrium. It's
stagnant. There's no innovation going
on. There's a lot of competition between
the upper nobility and low lower
nobility. Okay, so the low ability plot
was probably helping Alexander um um
conquer Persia. Two things I wanted to
keep keep you to understand about this
map. First of all is like the moment
that um Axer reaches Persia, he goes to
Troy. Why does he go to Troy? Because
Achilles went to Troy. So Axander saw
himself as the new Achilles. Okay. In
fact, um he had memorized the Iliad and
he took the Iliad with him wherever he
went. Okay, so that's the first thing I
I want you to um appreciate. Also, what
he did during the war was he took one of
his enemies, tied his enemy to the back
of his chariot and rolled the guy
around, okay? Just like Achilles did to
Hector. The other thing that's really
important, even more important is like
you see what happened when he visits
Egypt. Okay? He conquers Egypt and then
he decides to go all the way over here
to Ammon. Okay. Why does he do that?
Because there's a oracle at Ammon and he
spent a few days with his oracle and his
oracle told him his secret. The secret
is this.
You are not the son of Philen. You're
the son of God, which who is Zeus Aman.
Okay? So Zeus is the king of king of the
gods in the Greek tradition. Aman is
king of the gods in the Egyptian
tradition. So in other words, Alexander
was born to rule the world. who was
destined to conquer the world. And this
explains why when he conquered most of
Persia and Darius said to him, "You know
what? Here's a billion dollars. Go
away." As like, "No, screw you. I want
all of this." Okay, not only that, but
even after he conquered Piperilus, which
the capital of Persian Empire, he kept
on going to India. Okay. The only reason
why he stopped is his soldiers got sick
of fighting.
Um the other thing about Alexander
that's really important is he was known
for his atrocities. So he burned down
the city of thieves and he burned down
the city of Piperilus.
Why would he do that? Well um if you
understood that he saw himself a son of
god then it's possible we we'll never
know. Okay it's possible that burning
down thieves and burning down pipulus
were ritual sacrifices necessary to
prove that he was a son of God. Okay. So
yeah, he did a lot of like bad things,
but there's really nothing um random
about what he did. He thinks he the
things he did were for diplomatic
military purposes. Okay. [snorts]
All right.
So um this is a map of his conquest.
Okay.
Um this is a burning of Pipulus. You can
actually still visit Pipilus uh today in
Iran. Okay.
um what he was doing while his conquest
was that he was slowly killing off his
father's most loyal man. So Parmmen who
was um Phil's top general Alexander
killed and then Cletus who was also not
top general he killed as well. Okay now
his historically we remember these
events as um random acts of violence but
they're not. Okay. Alexander slowly need
to kill off his father's men so that he
could create his own empire. Okay.
Um and so what happened was that
eventually the other generals were like
you know eventually Axen is going to
come going to kill us as well. So they
conspired and poison him. And now what
they will do is they will fight amongst
themselves and create the Greek world.
Okay. It's divided into um four major
parts. And the four major parts are
Tommy takes Egypt which is the
wealthiest part of the empire. Um then
you have Macedon then you have Anatolia
and then you have the Seucian Empire.
Okay. All right.
So the problem though is like once you
conquer most of the world um you have to
rule over the world and there are that
many Greeks. So what they will do is
they will build Greek cities to settle
their veterans, invite more Greeks to
come, help them govern
um um the empire, but they also need
need to recruit bureaucrats. Okay? So um
they recruit these Persian bureaucrats
because they're very effective, but they
also recruit Jews as well into the
empire. Okay? Because Jews are a foreign
people. Okay? Because remember the
because these people the Greeks need to
omit to control and manage their empire.
Okay. All right. So what I want you to
focus now is on Egypt. Okay. Because
historically Egypt was the center of the
world. It was the cultural capital of
the world and Egypt helped to help give
science and math to uh Greece. Okay. Now
the Greeks are like controlling Egypt
and the Egypt is like wait a minute
here. You guys were barbarians. Now
you're controlling us. Why is this
happening? So now the Greeks need to
explain what's happening. And so what
they do is they create cultural
imperialism. All right.
Okay. Uh this is um the Greek world. So
they're building Greek cities all around
um the world. And these cities are very
similar. There's an epitheater. Sorry.
Uh this is a better map. Okay. This is
per pamont. Okay. So you can see what it
looks like. You have an epithe stage
Greek theater. You have a gyasium. You
have um an agora. Like they're like if
you go to these cities, they're all very
similar to each other.
Okay. And this is Greek art which takes
over the world as well.
All right. Let's just tell them in a
second. and he and his father taught him
the first they will create something
called the library of Alexandria. Okay.
[snorts]
The library of Alexandria what what what
it will do is it will take all the Greek
knowledge in the world and it it will
systemize it and synize it as textbooks
to be taught throughout the world. Okay.
So this is really a university.
um to show you how wealthy the Egyptians
are, the uh when they built the library
of of Alexandria, they um needed
original manuscripts. And so they said
to a Athenians, "Hey, can we borrow some
original plays?" And the Greeks are
like, "No, you can't. Uh because we
really love our upidities and our iss
you can't just take this stuff. This
this stuff is priceless." And the
Egyptians said, "You know what we'll do?
we'll give you like a billion dollars as
a deposit. And the Athenians, well,
that's a lot of money. Oh, sure. Okay.
All right. So, the Athenians lend these
scrolls to the Egyptians
um in Alexandria to copy. And then after
some time, the Athenians said said to
Tommy, "Hey man, give give us back the
scrolls." And the Tommy is like, "Keep
the money."
That's how wful they were. They had all
the money in the world. They didn't
care. Keep the money. $10 million. Keep
the money, man. And the Athenians were
pissed. Okay, they were really really
pissed about this. Don't ever trust. Uh
yeah. Anyway, this is Library of
Alexander. It's part of something called
the Musead. Okay, so what's really
important for us to understand is that a
university is not really about
education. It's not really about
literacy, culture. It's really about a
tool of empire to um create a cultural
understanding of the world that allows
the empire to rule over people. Okay. So
the library of of sorry [clears throat]
the library of Exanua is an example of
this because remember the Greeks are
ruling over the Egyptians. The Egyptians
are like why are you ruling over us and
the um Greeks are like because we're
culturally superior to you. And how do
you prove it? by
uh censoring Egyptian culture, okay? By
by um downplaying Egyptian culture and
by uh upplaying by promoting Greek
culture. Okay, this is cultural
imperialism.
Now this is really important as part of
the cultural imperialist project. Um the
Egyptians under Tommy, they also started
to work with the Jews. Okay? Why?
Because Egypt Egypt needed to control
the Levant as as well. Okay, who's in
the Leavant? The Jews. The Jews are
problematic because they were loyal to
the Persian Empire. Okay, so how do you
make them loyal to you? Well, you bribe
them. How do you bribe them? By getting
their priests, by saying the priest, you
know what? We love your tradition. We
love your culture. Let us translate your
Bible into Greek so that we can
celebrate your Bible and spread it
around the world. And this is what we
call the Septuagent. The Septuagent.
Okay, it's really important uh in our
history. Um and so the Jews were like,
"Yeah, that's a great great thing." But
not only that, but because
um of the library of Alexandria, a lot
of Jews were going to Alexandria to help
contribute to the scholarship there.
Okay? So eventually a third of the
people in of Alexandria will become
Jews. Okay? But Jews are spreading
throughout
the Greek world. And so now what you're
seeing is a massive secretism between
all three major religions. Okay? The
Greeks, the Jews, and the Persians.
Because the Persians are are
administrators in this empire. Uh the
Greeks are ruling this empire and the
Jews are helping build this empire.
Okay. So this will merge all three major
worldviews and this will give us
Christianity. Okay.
All right. So that is the Greek world.
All right. Um any questions?
Was was this clear?
>> Okay. So what will happen is like next
class we'll discuss Rome. Okay. because
Rome will now conquer this um empire and
then this will allow for the rise of
Christianity and we will do this next
week. Okay. So everything was clear
today, right?
Come